[Musica]
quante volte ci siamo chiesti in questi
mesi come ritrovare le emozioni le
emozioni ammazzate dalla separazione ma
anche le emozioni che appartengono per
esempio allo spettacolo dal vivo o alla
danza
ecco il primo periodo dell'anno scorso
noi abbiamo occupato proprio cercando di
rispondere a questo poi ci siamo accorti
che nella ricerca nella ricerca di
qualche cosa di nuovo
avremmo trovato delle soluzioni non
soltanto per l'oggi per la difficoltà
dell'emergenza ma anche per il futuro
perché in fondo
quell'emozione speciale che appartiene
al rapporto tra un interprete e uno
spettatore
ecco quelle mozione specifica può anche
essere addirittura amplificata da certi
strumenti tecnologici e qui ci siamo
veramente appassionati siamo andati alla
ricerca un po tentoni naturalmente di
quelle che potevano essere le soluzioni
anche gli spazi possibili per andare a
recuperare qualche cosa addirittura in
più bene per un danzatore in rapporto
con il pubblico è assolutamente
fondamentale ma il pubblico è sempre al
di là della quarta parete nella
possibilità di girare in realtà virtuale
nella possibilità di creare una specie
di magico box intorno all'occhio dello
spettatore noi abbiamo visto una
possibilità straordinaria di prossimità
che lo spettatore non ha mai di cura e
attenzione alla visione del dettaglio e
anche perché no di emozione se poi
quell'incontro fosse risultato
particolarmente riuscito in questo
naturalmente abbiamo anche intravisto
una grande sfida tecnologica per la
quale siamo andati alla ricerca di aiuto
ecco quando
ci è stato proposto questa sfida
tecnologica
quando abbiamo cominciato a ragionare
sulla possibilità di introdurre degli
elementi di immersività della danza e di
fare in modo che il coinvolgimento di
tutti i protagonisti di queste
esperienze i danzatori coreografo e
anche il pubblico potessero in qualche
modo essere innestati in un contesto
nuovo in un contesto dove le dinamiche
sono cambiate dove le distanze sono
diventate nella necessità ci siamo
immediatamente resi conto di quanto
fosse rilevante e significativa questa
sfida tecnologica e abbiamo in qualche
modo fatto quello che facciamo di solito
cioè come dire esplorato
tra le opzioni tecnologiche indagato su
come queste si potessero sposare con le
esperienze degli utenti ma anche
l'esperienza dei protagonisti del tema
delle esperienze che si andava
realizzando e alla fine dopo una
riflessione nella quale il dialogo è
continuato in questo sta anche uno degli
aspetti interessanti di questo lavoro
siamo approdati all'idea di realizzare
quella che tecnicamente si chiama la
cinematic dual cioè l'idea di una
rappresentazione in realtà immersiva
quindi l'idea che il pubblico sia in
qualche modo collocato dentro a una
situazione di immersività dicevo la
rappresentazione però di una forma
visiva autentica non di una
ricostruzione tridimensionale non di un
lavoro di elaborazione digitale ma
esattamente l'autenticità del lavoro del
coreografo dello scenario di danza e
dunque anche un ruolo da protagonista
nel caso specifico dei danzatori
ecco è uscita un'esperienza che abbiamo
colto tutti come nuova e peculiare
ancora una volta la possibilità per il
pubblico di indossare questo dispositivo
di immersione completa anche poi in una
versione per così dire più light
attraverso un tablet consente appunto
allo spettatore di vivere una sorta di
totale immersione della danza quindi di
vedere e la danzatrice il danzatore
muoversi nello spazio ma anche le deve
lo spazio muoversi intorno alla danza
quindi c'è un gioco nel quale io mi giro
io spettatore mi giro e vedo tutto
quello che accade intorno a lei nel
momento in cui questo succede succede
che anche l'audio anche la parte
acustica che così importante
dell'elemento emozionare di questa
restituzione
segue lo spazio mi attornia mimì insegue
propriamente ecco che a quel punto
l'esperienza di mercy vita è importante
e significativa è totale ma è così anche
perché il dialogo non si è fermato ad
una risposta tecnologica di fronte a una
sia pur a interessante sollecitazioni
intellettuale o sollecitazione per così
dire estetica ma è continuato nella
valutazione degli impatti i primi
prototipi ci hanno consentito di capire
che cosa andava e che cosa poteva essere
migliorato
abbiamo lavorato con le persone con gli
utenti con gli stessi protagonisti
danzatori coreografi e abbiamo capito
per esempio che l'esperienza immersiva e
insieme avvincente ma anche a tratti
perturbante perché in qualche modo ti
porta quasi ad essere invaso dall
esperienza di danza e questo è un
elemento che ci ha per così dire
sorpresi e incuriositi e nuovamente a
tratti concludo questa riflessione
dicendo che in fondo abbiamo creato in
questo dialogo molto stimolante
una sorta di nuova grammatica della
progettazione una nuova forma di
contribuire alla danza attraverso la
tecnologia e che ha come dicevi tu dei
tratti e dei passaggi interessanti sui
quali naturalmente lascio a te una
conclusione di insieme la cosa più
straordinaria della nostra esperienza è
che non siamo abituati al coreografo che
prende in considerazione lo spettatore
il coreografo di solito a uno spazio e
dei corpi e questa è il suo modo di
organizzare la relazione con lo
spettatore in questo caso no
i nostri coreografi hanno dovuto
immaginare di far convivere l'interprete
e lo spettatore nello stesso spazio
hanno dovuto rivolgersi ad un
immaginario spettatore che quando poi
coi oculis
si ritrovano al centro della scena si
sentono veramente parte della
performance e non vi hanno soltanto
assistito
[Musica]
e un premio